el consejo de seguridad de Naciones
Unidas acaba de aprobar por unanimidad
una resolución presentada por Estados
Unidos y por México para acabar con esa
ola de violencia que asola al pueblo
haitiano que atraviesa una de sus peores
crisis con secuestros violaciones una
crisis financiera y por supuesto ese
brote de cólera se trata de una
resolución como digo aprobada por
unanimidad incluso por Rusia y China que
al principio se mostraban reticentes y
que va a imponer una serie de sanciones
a los grupos armados violentos que hay
en Haití que tienen controlada una gran
parte del país infraestructuras y
también comunicaciones entre las
sanciones va a estar la congelación de
las cuentas bancarias de los líderes de
estos grupos armados tampoco podrán
viajar y además se van a confiscar armas
a los actores no estatales la
representante de Estados Unidos en el
Consejo de Seguridad linda
un primer paso para demostrar a estas
personas que tienen secuestrada a Haití
lo que pueden llegar a hacer y que va a
haber un castigo si no actúan bien lo
que se está refiriendo a la
representante de Estados Unidos es que
está preparando junto con México una
segunda resolución en esta segunda
resolución se incluye enviar fuerzas
armadas a la isla para devolver el
control al gobierno esta resolución está
tardando un poco más porque de momento a
China y Rusia se muestran bastante
reticentes a probarla